نقيضان بوجهه واحده امراتان بهدف واحد
امهات وبنات بين ثقافتين هو تعليق الفنانه
اللبنانيه مياه علاوي على صورتها مع
والدتها سريلانكيه على حسابها بانستقرام
والتي نالت اعجاب الكثيرين فيما شكل صدمه
للبعض الاخر من المولوده لابلو لبنان وهم
سريلانكيه بدات كومبارس في فيلم من بطوله
هيفاء وهبي حصدت اليوم نجاحات بالتمثيل
كما اشتهرت ايضا كعارضه ازياء ظهرت
مشاهدينا في عده برامج تلفزيونيه تحدثت
فيها عن قيامها سابقا لمساعده والدتها
العامل المنزليه في تنظيف المنازل
ومعاناتها مع شقيقاتها من التنمر هذا ربما
ما دفعها لتجسد قصه حياتها ومعاناتها مع
التنمر والعنصريه في مسلسل بنت سريلانكيه
وتفتخر باصلها
[موسيقى]
انا ايفون
خالتي اختها لامها لاول مره بحياتي
[موسيقى]
من بيروت الممثله مياه علاوي اهلا فيك
معنا في صباح العربيه نورتينا يعني ومنوره
صباح الخير صباح الفل
ابتسامه الحلوه
ميه انت مثال لشخص قدري حول شيء سلبي
عنصريه
تنمر لا اشي كتير ايجابي احكيلنا اكثر هيك
يعني عن هاي التجربه كيف فكرتي يعني انك
تحولي شي يعتبر ببعض المجتمعات منها
المجتمع اللبناني وصمه وصمه عار لشيء بهذا
الاشراق وهذا الجمال وهذا التفاؤل
والافاده ايضا
صراحه ما كان عندي ابدا الهدف انه انا
اطلع او احكي او اعمل مسلسل بس كان كل
حياتي اقول انه بدي شي نهار اوصل وعن جد
فرجه للمجتمع قديه العنصريه او البولينج
شي مش حلو فوصلت
من شي اربع سنين وكنت قاعده هيك عم بدرس
وطلعت معي عنوانكيه لانه عن جد كنت كتير
اسمع بحياتي وقلت رح اكتب قصه حياتي مش
كرمالي بس لانه انا وقتها كنت عم بشتغل
كان في كتير عالم كمان من البشر السوداء
معي كنت عنجد شوف التعامل مثل ما كنت انا
كانوا يتعاملوا معي بس يمكن ايجروسكن صرت
اكثر عندي جراه طالب بحقي
فطلعت معي هذه الفكره انه احكي عن هذا
الموضوع من بعد ما شفت كل هو لقلت انه
لازم يكون لو صوت صغير
بكل تواضع عم بيحكي عن هذا الموضوع بهذا
المجتمع اول شيء يعني الخلطه اللبنانيه
السريلانكيه حلوه واثنين يعني انت مش اول
لبنانيه ربما تعاني من هذا الشيء من اصحاب
البشره السمراء اليوم ماذا يعني ان تكون
امك سريلانكيه ماذا يعني ان تكوني
بالمدرسه
بمجال عملك يعيطوا لك يا بنت السريلانكيه
تخيل انت حدا يجي عم بعيرك بجنسيه اهلك او
عم بعيرك بلونك يلي هو انت اصلا ما عندك
اي سلطه على انك تغيرها وما عندها كمان
اهلك الوعي انه يجوا يقولوا لك انه هيدا
الشي طبيعي او ما في وعي اجتماعي يقول لك
انه انت لازم تندمج بهذا المجتمع ومنك
مختلف هذا الشيء باثر على النفسيه باثر
على كيف تكوين الشخصيه كيف تتعامل كيف
تاخد قرارات طيب ما البعض اذا كان يعني
امك من جنسيه اخرى غير اللبنانيه ينظر
اليها ايضا بنظره اقل من الجنسيه
اللبنانيه ماذا اذا كانت
سريلانك هي وهي تعني العماله المنزليه
انتقاص ماذا يعني ذلك على طول عمرك اللي
عانيتيه
هلا انت بعدك عم بتقولي انه قديش في عندك
مجتمعاتنا للاسف بعد في بولينج على البشره
السمراء بس الفكره انه انا عم بكتب قصتي
كرمال بس تونارمل لحتى يكون هذا الموضوع
شي طبيعي مش بس كمان من هذا الشيء بدي
اقول لامي thank you لانه قدره نضالت
وربتنا بطريقه وخلتنا نكون مثقفين نقدر
نطلع نحكي يمكن انا عم بقول لها هلا ميرسي
من خلال هذا المسلسل بس المسلسل بيحكي عن
قصه حياتي وعن امي وكيف اجت على لبنان وشو
تعرضنا بلبنان انا واخواتي وهو مش بس عن
العنصريه هو عنصر العنصريه بالمسلسل عم
بيكون هو التوث بكل حدث عم بيصير بكل قرار
عم بيصير بكل شيء عم نتعرض له كان
العنصريه مبطنه فكل الاوقات عم يكون نحن
عم بتعامل معنا بطريقه ثانيه شو ما كانت
السيويشن لانه امي او لانه انا بنت المراه
اللي بشرتها داكنه وراح يكون من انتاج
لبناني ام رح تطلعي من حدود لبناني يمكن
فيما يتعلق بالانتاج صراحه بكل صراحه انا
كنت عم بعرض حكيت قبل عن هذا الموضوع وانا
الابراجكت بعده ما حدا تبنيه انحكى فيه من
انتاج لبناني بس صار في ديلاي بالموضوع
فانا من هون عم برجع ارجع اشدد على انه
اذا في انتاج بهمه التوعيه الاجتماعيه عن
هذا الموضوع بهموا الصحه حقيقيه مش بس
لانه الفيلم كل حياتها هي انه نوعي
المجتمع ففي قصه حقيقيه موجوده بس اذا في
حدا مهتم بهذا الموضوع
اكيد كان هناك ايضا روايه ساق البامبو
لسعود السنعوسي واخذت جائزه هناك ايضا
مسلسل الان يعرض لهدى حسين يتحدث ايضا عن
معاناه اصحاب البشره
السمراء في مجتمعاتنا شكرا
التي كانت معنا من بيروت شكرا جزيلا صباحك
سعيد لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات